sine x plus cos x right this looks a
little familiar to me right
um i've been adding trig functions as
part of what we've been doing
under identities right for instance if i
told you this
sine of a plus b
sine of a plus b right we learned an
identity this quite early on actually
what was our identity for this thing
side a cos b
plus cos a side b good
okay right now what i've got here bears
some resemblance
to this doesn't it right i've got a sign
and a cause but then there are these
kind of other guys
floating around so what do i do with
them okay
well that extra angle is this
right how is it that you actually change
the phase of a trig function
suppose i wanted to take like just
regular old sine x
and i wanted to move a tail i don't know
90 degrees
to the right what would i do
to the right how would i have to change
this function in here i'd have to go y
equals sign
x minus 90 degrees right
x minus 20. that would change the phase
wouldn't it okay
or if i wanted to move it to the left it
takes plus 90
right so here's what i'm putting across
to you right
this thing here is another wave function
it's like a sine or a cosine
right but its amplitude is changed and
its phase is changed right so here's
what i'm going to suggest
that sine x plus cos x sum of two wave
functions
should be equivalent to that's
an identity by the way it's not just at
certain values i mean
at all values all the way across right
it should be equivalent to
a sine function another wave function
with a different amplitude
and a different phase
so let me just say that again say it
again
because this is the crucial idea and the
rest of it's just
algebra and identities right i'm saying
i'm saying i'm putting cross to you and
i hope i made enough of a visual
argument
that the sum of two wave functions is
equivalent to
not just equal to it's exactly the same
at all points along
as some other wave function with a
different amplitude
and a different phase it's been moved
around
somehow okay now this thing is called
it's named after that phase
right this angle here right it's like x
and a little bit of an angle like an
angle on the side and a phrase
on the side or word i should say is
called
auxiliary angle right auxiliary means
it's like extra
right it's like a little bit that i've
added on right when um
when something says oh we need to go to
auxiliary power it's like your main
your main thing is shut down and you've
got to use like the battery on the side
right
it's literally the main angle plus a
little bit that's that's all it means
okay so this thing this idea is called
auxiliary
so what are three lines mean people
we've looked at this before
we look we used it in the context of
triangles we said it's congruent
in the context of trig what does it mean
it means equal and
always equal to for every value of x
right
get ready we're going to pull together a
lot of things that you've been looking
at over the last couple of weeks
and it's going to this is kind of like
the conclusion of it right so just off
of this line right
this line here i know what this is equal
to i know what this is equal to
right it's just an expansion right
so i've got r outside of okay now this
is sine a cos b
cos a sine b right so let's do it sine x
cos alpha cos x
sine alpha you okay with that
okay so far so good now keep in mind
keep in mind alpha is equal to something
it's not a variable
right i really should have said i really
should have said
alpha is a number right it's a real
number of some kind we'll find out what
it is
soon but it's completely different to x
yes it's another pronumeral
but it has a value like it's not it's
not odd whatever i want to be
it's this distance here i'm going to
find out what it is okay
so that's what i have on the right hand
side over here on the left i still have
this guy
hasn't changed okay now look with me
right
do you see on the left hand side i have
assigned her
and on the right hand side i also have a
side turn
and on the left hand side i have a
cosine term and on the right hand side i
also have a constant
okay so these guys inform each other
right remember i'm saying
this is exactly the same as this just
written in another way
okay so i'm going to expand and show you
what this is equal to
this thing here is actually it's
shorthand it's one sine x
plus one cos x you're thinking why am i
adding the one in well you'll see in a
second
okay when i expand this out i'm going to
expand it in such a way
to make the sine x really the sine x
term really obvious
and the cosine x term really obvious i'm
going to expand yeah so i've got
r cos alpha
and then i've got sine x do you agree
with that
that's just me i've just slightly
reordered it is just a regular
yeah it's just a regular it's not an r
for real numbers okay
that's what i've done with the first
term i'll expand the next one
ah sine alpha and then there's that cos
x
hanging out on the side okay can you see
why i have written this kind of unusual
why have i got brackets way okay because
this one right this coefficient of the
sine x
is that coefficient of the sine x
it's just written in a different way
okay so r cos alpha which is just a
number
it's one and in the same way in this
particular example
r sine alpha is also equal to one
okay and then my sine x's and my cos x's
i just hang off on the side
okay so i would say and you don't have
to write this every time but this is the
first time
so let's let's make sure we understand
what's going on by equating
coefficients that's what we're doing
right the coefficient
of sine x on the left hand side and the
coefficient of sine x on the right hand
side
they're meant to be the same they're
equivalent right so we equate them
we would say r cos alpha equals one
in this particular case and our sine
alpha
is also equal to one i just chose a
really simple example for you
okay
sir i said mark lane and
all right now at this point what are we
trying to do
like so far you've just been following
along because i've been dragging you
with me right
what i'm trying to find is the amplitude
has changed
how has it changed you already have an
educated guess as to how it's changed
and how has the phase
changed what angle have i been moved
across by okay
so there was something else i should
have mentioned which is that not only is
alpha real but um
r is the amplitude here so amplitude is
a positive number
yes that's what it is that's right okay
so what am i going to do with this there
are two things you can do
one thing is cheap and it's a quick fix
which kind of gets you an answer
it's not as good and another way is
longer but it will give you a more sure
answer
okay so i will show you the long one
i'll show you the
short one later on after you know how to
do it properly
okay so here's what i'm going to do
equation one
equation two okay notice this is a set
of simultaneous equations
i have two unknowns r and alpha
and i have two equations perfect that's
exactly the setup i mean
here's what i'm gonna do i'm going to
put them together in a kind of unusual
way
you're not used to seeing this right and
usually we would say oh it's a bad idea
to square things because you add
solutions and so on okay
but in this particular case watch what
happens okay
1 squared right on the left hand side
i'll have r
squared cos squared alpha yeah
on the right hand side i'll have 1
squared which is 1.
what happens to equation 2 it's going to
become r
squared sine squared alpha what happens
to the right hand side
it becomes 1. okay so now here
i've got a cos squared plus sine squared
so when i
factor out r squared out the front
i'm left with cos squared plus sine
squared which is 1.
which is 2 on the right hand side
so remember because i said r is positive
that r is the square root of 2
which is exactly what you were expecting
wasn't it so i have an amplitude now
tick okay i'm not finished not finished
i found r right but now i need to find
out what alpha is
okay so i've got to use both these
equations here and you'll see why
shortly
okay i've got um r is root 2 so i can
say root 2
cos alpha equals 1 from equation 1
and i can say root 2 sine alpha is equal
to 1 as well from equation 2
right so just rearrange just a little
bit make alpha as close to the subject
as possible
i've got this and i've got this
okay now you're like hold on a second is
it redundant wasn't it like usually when
you have simultaneous equations
you find a solution right and then you
just substitute that into whichever one
you want
and you get an answer for the other one
can you see why
i need to put r into both equations
in order to know which answer i want
right
yeah maybe
kind of it's because let me think about
this let's just think about this
if i just stopped here right and did the
top part which is from equation one
right aha what angles does
cos alpha equal one number two the
answer is uh causes like this
is going to be 45 and 315.
quadrant one quadrant four right so i
don't know which one it is
but once i bring this guy in i have the
same solution
so alpha has to satisfy both of these
cos is positive
side is positive what quadrant am i in
quadrant one
so it has to be alpha must be
45 and only 45. okay
now let me just use that as my
opportunity to
point out to you the cheap way which
which does get taught and it's kind of
as a shortcut it's not that bad um but
it has a big problem and it's the
problem we just solved okay
here this line this line this is not the
only way
you can put together these equations
just like with normal simultaneous
equations
you can do elimination or you can do
substitution
right we've kind of done i don't know
what you call that
squaring anyhow there's another thing we
can do this okay if you're really really
sneaky
you're like all i need to do is
eliminate one of the variables
right now the way we did this was we
eliminated
alpha correct no more alphas
you can eliminate r from there can't you
yeah can i do
r over the second equation
yeah two divided by one
that'll work and it looks really elegant
watch this if i'm dividing
this by this what happens to the r's
disappears right
then you'll get sign up from cos alpha
10 you get one over one
and you say sure enough well that's 45
isn't it
isn't it or or and here's your problem
or 225. okay now you guys know
because you've looked at this graph
you're like oh yeah clearly that
that looks like 45 to me it is 45 okay
but you don't have information from this
process that tells you which one it
really is
right whereas this one does you see how
i've got two equations and it locks in
which one i'm actually after